absolutely so today being a special day
to celebrate your spouse or maybe build
the anticipation to valentine's day
which is right around the corner it's
january 26th
not january 6th you could show your love
for your significant other with
flower arrangements rocchio rocky is
over in studio with an idea to help us
get into that
spirit hey rocky hey guys okay you guys
are so
cute i love those photos i can't quite
celebrate national spouses day over here
but i can
celebrate valentine's day or maybe
galentine's day so if you need ideas
i've brought in the experts so let's
welcome in kendall
from local flower shop empress flora who
is going to show us a very
special but simple way to show love
right kendall
right all right well i've been keeping
an eye on you guys
um instagram such beautiful arrangements
so just first tell us
a little bit about empress flora and
what you guys specialize in
yeah sorry especially in dried florals
so
mainly roses hydrangeas and baby breath
and we put them
in lovely boxes they come in 169r1
and recon stems as well so
these last year a year and longer wow
you've got a nice setup over there how
did i do with mine
we tried my camera guys and i we really
put our you know our all into this
for the spirit right okay so if people
are trying to you know save a little
money or get creative maybe
do a diy for their loved one we have
some ideas right we're going to
share a diy arrangement for everybody
right yeah so you can just take a vase
mason jar is usually something that
everyone has on hand
um we have flower petals so we could
just fill the flower petals
put some holes anything like that and
then you can just
take some of your forever roses
and then go ahead and put them in your
vase
and then do nothing non-traditional
different colors
so i see how important are the colors do
you think
people can find a lot of unique colors
with you guys i see blue
i see yellow yes yes
each color means something red
stands for like passion yellow
symbolizing for honor joy
white purity pure things like that yes
you can definitely communicate your love
with someone with the rose and the color
i love that so thoughtful
and i really quickly i just need to know
how do you guys dry these roses because
we were thinking
it's so hard you at home you gotta like
hang them upside down and do all these
things but you guys have a special way
you do it
yeah so we actually have our own uh
parent facility in colombia
so they harvest them and do it all
in-house and then everything is made to
order
so it's preserved out of its clothes
bloom making sure that we get a nice
full bloom and it's gonna look beautiful
the entire time
oh my gosh so beautiful well how did i
do this
here we are here's my display can you
guys see that
yes it looks amazing the petals at the
bottom for a little texture a little
texture
exactly exactly okay so now let's talk
about
everything else you guys have to offer
here because i see this gorgeous
white rose display here and what i love
the most
what i love most is that they last
forever
explain that to everybody yeah so those
are our pink rose box um it comes with
24
white roses and they smell
amazing you can add some extra oils
there it looks amazing you can decorate
it yourself if you want to
oh my gosh they wow i didn't even know
they had a scent they smelled so good
okay so before we wrap up kendall i have
to
i have to show off what you guys did for
las vegas now and my my cast and crew
has not seen this yet
so everybody look at the channel 8 las
vegas now empress flora
display with the blue roses
thank you so much kendall you're very
welcome thank you
all right we're going to spread love and
rise to the occasion
this year huh i'll send it back to you
guys